so today with pancetta and chestnuts
these are sprouts like you've never
tasted before and Brussels sprouts are
delicious
when they cooked perfectly packed with
texture and the flavor is extraordinary
take off the outer leaves trim the
bottom and cut in half as the big step
up from the crisscross on the bottom but
my mother used to do every Christmas I'm
cutting them in half so when I started
them they cook evenly alone it's like
that all baby cabbages is so compact
then blast and in salted boiling water
for two minutes
now this is the most amazing pancetta
lightly cured pancetta is a type of
Italian bacon which is born in for
adding a lovely rich meaty flavor to
dishes on a really nice robust flavor to
go with that earthy texture of the
sprout it's made from pork belly and is
dry cured with salt and aromatics like
juniper bay leaves nutmeg dried thyme
and garlic as it hits the pan that fat
on top of the pancetta melts and gives
the Sprouse this amazing flavor
after removing the skin cut into small
chunks if you can't get hold of pancetta
smoke streaky bacon is a good
alternative no hot pan a teaspoon of
olive oil give it a like seasoning with
salt and pepper
as the lava start to crisp up take your
sprouts out drain them
Frandsen
now give her a really nice little sauce
then chop up a handful of chestnuts now
the test us sweeten the flavor of the
sprout really important that you don't
put the chestnuts in too early otherwise
they'll go mush and then just sprinkle
the chestnuts over
so we've managed to turn a sort of
playing James sprout into something
quite delicious you got the texture the
smoked bacon the so Tate's sprout and
that nice crunch and sweetness of a
festive chestnut
10 seconds before the come out lemon
zest over now that makes the sprouts and
the bacon harmonized
and then just the squeeze of fresh lemon
juice over the sprouts beautiful
this right now is the ultimate and for
me that's a really nice modern 21st
century approach to cook in an
old-fashioned vegetable after ten
minutes take the turkey out of the oven
and baste then cover the breasts with
smoked streaky bacon what I want to do
is add a little bit more flavor and
basically what's happening now is that
we're giving the gravy a little bit of
body pour in the chicken stock and
reduce again